here's the big news of the day I think
it's fair to say there's probably other
news but let's I I'll be real very slow
news day that's true but this was the
most fun story Texas National Guard
flies come and take it flag as border
tensions grow this is it take a look at
this do you guys know what the Gonzalez
flag is they have this picture what I
love about it is the flag shows it's
kind of hard to see on the screen it
shows artillery a single star and it
says come and take it and it was
basically uh you know in Texas these
guys had a cannon and and there was some
you know military officer I think it was
Mexican and he was like you are going to
surrender that Cannon to me and they
made that flag and said come and take it
and it's just this little artillery it's
not very big and it's just one but this
symbol that was made that day is it's
powerful and right now there's concerns
that Joe Biden will make moves to
federalize the National Guard Abbott
says nationalizing Texas National Guard
would be a severe Biden political
blunder but we don't know exactly what's
going to happen I I think a lot of
people uh the smart move on Biden's part
is to slow down and back off and let
things simmer down otherwise if he makes
a move it can escalate quickly out of
his control but of course because that
happens everybody seems to think nothing
will happen I don't know that that's the
case considering all the other news that
we've been seeing and the fact that even
with Texas National Guard putting up the
razor wire this has not stopped the bill
that's being proposed where Joe Biden's
like I've done everything I can you to
give me the power the bill they're
proposing would give Joe Biden 5,000
criminal aliens I'm not talking about
migrants or ases or whatever 5,000
criminal aliens every day would be
allowed to cross that's the deal Joe
Biden basically I got I got to give it
to him he's a mass he must have read the
art of the deal WR some Donald Trump the
big ask Joe Biden allows wave after wave
of criminal migrant to come in this
country and then says how about we stop
it at 5,000 and that's a deal
brutal I I don't know where this goes
Texas Texas National Guard I know you've
been down there quite a bit and you've
seen some of this I'm curious your
thoughts Taylor yeah well I mean just in
Shelby Park in an Eagle pass in specific
I mean it is cleaned up it is day and
night difference I mean was down there I
would say at the beginning of January
and I mean they went I did a little tour
with National Guard they were nice
enough to let me in and actually go and
see the razor wire and you know they
kind of gave me the ends of how many
Crossings had actually been stopped on
average they were averaging anywhere
when I was down there it was six to four
migrants a day compared to you know I
was there the month prior no 6 to four
that's it wa with with National Guard in
Shelby Park in one of the regions in the
Del Rio sector that used to be one of
the most popular and I mean they were
shattering records every single month
per day yeah well in the month before
that if you guys saw the kind of makeup
apprehension site where you had
thousands I mean filling in every single
10 minutes as one line is cleared
another line fills that's how much of a
difference that it has made in that one
sector so now you're seeing Rises in the
Arizona sectors and migrants are making
their way over there or 15 miles you
know Upland and now they're Crossing in
that area but it's still not nearly as
much is working this is the challenge of
separate states sovereign states the
Biden Administration as a federal agency
just wants to bring in criminal criminal
aliens so when Texas say says we're
going to push back all the Biden
Administration has to do is well I
shouldn't say the bid Administration but
whoever is communicating with the
cartels to let them know how to operate
send them send them to Iona I'm sure
they got CBP down there that's willing
to facilitate the the human Smugglers
operations and if anybody who lives
there tries to defend their property we
we'll put him in prison that seems to be
the case and this wasn't the case under
uh dug duy Who had who was really
supportive of Abbott he also bust people
out of state uh it's apparent to me how
obvious the changes in our state
leadership are to people in other
countries right we have we know people
pay attention to the America's um
presidential elections but I think the
turnover from a republican Governor to a
Democratic governor immediately opened
up Arizona in a way that became apparent
to the International Community that's
looking to perforate the Border yeah
well in Arizona is an absolute mess
right now if you look at like Ali
Bradley or any of the reporters of the
news nation that are down there they
done a really good job at covering it
and now you're seeing numbers spike in
that area once again while the Del Rio
sector is drastically dropping and you
know there's a big difference between
those two sectors the kinds of migrants
that you get through you get a lot of
Chinese Nationals coming through in the
Arizona sectors they're treated a lot
differently in tapachula which is kind
of the conglomeration uh grounds in
Mexico where you know they're kind of
sent up I mean they have full-blown
hotels and you know routes and guides
for these Chinese people CU they have
more money so then they're guided into
over in you know the Tijana area and
they're treated you know with respect
they don't really have to go through the
cartels but the Venezuelans the
Hondurans those types that you're seeing
come through Eagle Pass consistently you
know they're often times being traded
from Cartel to cartel every single step
of the way would did when you were down
there before the National Guard shut
everything down right yep and then
afterwards as well so explain explain
expl like just what it looks like when
cbp's in charge when CBP is in charge is
an absolute mess I mean it is migrants
coming in at all times of the day all
times of the night most of the biggest
influxes you see is anywhere between
like 5: to 9:00 a.m. in the morning
that's really when you see them get hit
hard with the big Caravans that cross
over you'll have an NGO last time I was
in Mexico I like to report from the
Mexico side because I feel that's kind
of where the story actually is you can
follow the Caravans over and the NGS
they're located in Mexico they'll have
you know two double wide BAS Bally barn
doors that they have anywhere between a
few hundred to a thousand migrants in
that are ready to go that morning and
then they'll walk them down to the river
the coyote will if they have one and
then they'll cross them into the real gr
and then they'll be put in that
makeshift apprehension site at least
that's how it wasal Al yes you
accidentally said migrant yeah yeah I
have tremendous respect for migrants who
come to the United States believe in the
American dream apply at the appropriate
border crossing and say thank you for
everything you've you've you've every
opportunity you've afforded me I hope
that the the paperwork moves through and
I can come to your country well none of
them are actually going through the
checkpoints and that's for a reason well
no no no migrants are criminal aliens
are not yep and and that's the legal
term I I think uh you know uh shout out
James Lindsay he had this post where he
said do not use the leftist language it
is a political agenda so when we are
specifically referring to individuals
who are committing crimes against the
United States and against Texas and
they're being assisted by the Biden
Administration to which the Texas
governor has called out the Biden Adra
Administration for doing those are the
criminal criminal aliens and I just I
would not want to bch the good name of
migrants cuz I like migrants I I like
the people who respect this country it
doesn't mean they get to come in doesn't
mean they get to move here but sometimes
they do and through the appropriate
means that's beneficial to the economy
beneficial to the communities what's
going on with the with Southern border
and CBP and Biden is is the is the
antithesis it is destructive it is chaos
the crazy thing to me is as you describe
like these ngos bringing these big
Caravans what's their goal just sewing
chaos and hurting these people basically
every single step of the way I mean they
get paid every single step of the way a
lot of the NOS that operate in Mexico
are also operating in America so or
they're working together in some fashion
or some capacity so you'll have them
cross and then immediately after they're
done being processed the NGO will step
in which you know in Eagle Pass and all
these other border towns they quite
literally have buildings there and then
they start facilitating these migrants
and then uh you know the one in San
Antonio that I was at last month or at
the beginning of January where San
Antonio PD was essentially running
private security facilitating the human
smuggling of these illegals they quite
literally put them in this area for an x
amount of time and then they say Hey you
know if you can afford your own ticket
or they kind of phrase it in a little
more aggressive manner they try and get
these illegals to buy their own tickets
and then if they aren't willing to buy
their own tickets after a certain amount
of time or they can't afford it they'll
end up saying okay we can pay half and
then if they still can't afford it they
end up paying the full thing who's pay
who's paying it the NGS wow I mean they
should be they should be uh there should
be some kind of criminal uh
investigation charges against the
organizations for facilitating illegal
immigration I mean it's laughable CBP
the only reason the cartels and the
Smugglers are able to to operate is
because CBP was like we got you MH
absolutely well and that's the same
thing with the you know San Antonio PD
running security for this facility they
are essentially taking cartel money
because cartels will pay these NOS
because they're doing their dirty work
and their ground work for them and then
it's washed through San Antonio the city
of San Antonio essentially and then
given to these officers a higher rate
than they're already being paid which
San Antonio PD they're already getting
paid good money but they're still
willing to go and do this in uniform and
actually guard these migrant facilities
and essentially threaten you with arrest
if you keep asking them questions as
they did with me feels like there is a
boa constrictor on the neck of this
country slowly just squeezing and
squeezing and uh man the challenge is
discipline I feel like the best thing we
can do is hope that by voting for Donald
Trump he gets in and starts to reverse
course and there's no guarantees that
happens but that is the best path
forward we have right now that being
said Greg Abbott seems to have done a
lot to to Abate this but now now we need
Arizona and New Mexico to do the same
New Mexico won't New Mexico will always
just say we're an Open Door they're
Democrat run they're trying to ban guns
they're doing a whole bunch of crazy
stuff yeah New Mexico Arizona California
they're not going to do anything and
they think that's one of the reasons um
Abbott taking such a strong stance was a
rallying cry we saw so many what over 25
States said we're with you we're going
to support you and they aren't all
necessarily directly attached to the
Border but they feel the burdens of
illegal immigration as well we know that
especially the Biden Administration has
moved people who come illegally
throughout the country and this becomes
a nationwide problem I think for a long
time it was marketed as well it's just
Texas's problem it's just in the Border
communities and you know that
frustration really lit a fuse and I mean
operation Lone Star abits initiative to
to close the border and to add more
State um Power behind efforts to rest
RCT legal immigration has been going on
since 2021 I mean he launched it
alongside the Biden Administration and
they're really seeing this come to a
head after four years well you see a lot
of those states that are actually
signing on are actually receiving an
influx of illegal migrants too or I
should say criminal aliens as Tim States
it well that's that's the illegal term
of it and I mean even Utah I remember
when I was flying back from my San
Antonio and last Eagle Pass trip I'm
looking at these illegals uh pass I mean
these basically these boarding passes
that are makeshift and they're
completely different most of the time
than most other boarding passes and I'm
looking through some and I look at my
gate and I see six right there and I was
like there's no way they're coming to
Utah out of all places and lo and behold
they're coming to Utah they're in
Chicago they're being flown on private
jets I mean it's just absolutely nuts to
think you out there listen hardworking
American you lived your whole life you
followed the rules you don't break any
laws you got a job you went to school
you got married you had kids and you see
on Instagram and you see in the news
these people getting to fly on these
private jets and you think think you
know what did I have to do differently
in my life to be able to fly in a
private jet apparently you need to be
born in a third world country and then
illegally ENT the United States because
they are putting these people on large
private jets flying them through private
jet terminals to big cities giving them
hotel rooms cell phones and debit cards
with thousands of dollars in cash thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time